good evening
and welcome to uh this meeting of the
council
and also to all of our members here
and also our um
audience that are looking on youtube so
welcome
may i first remind you of some domestic
arrangements
the toilets are situated outside the
meeting room
if the fire alarm should sound please
leave the meeting room
by following the fire exit signs which
you can see hopefully
please switch off all mobile phones or
turn them to silent please
i would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast
live to the internet and will be capable
of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed
by entering this meeting you are also
consenting to be filmed by the council
and to the possible use of those images
and sound recordings
for all webcut webcasting and or
training purposes the council members
of the public and the press may recall
film photograph or broadcast this
meeting
when the public and the press are not
lawfully excluded
can i move to the agenda please
can i now ask the corporate manager for
governance and civic office to report
any apologies please
thank you chair i have received
apologies from councillor ayers
councillor mccraw and councillor melanie
barrett thank you
can i now ask item two
oh sorry i'm sorry um councilwood
from uh councillor norman he's uh not
well and i've advised him not to come
even though i probably couldn't do with
his vote tonight but um
it's best that he doesn't come
see your hand can i now turn to item two
declarations of interest by councillors
are there any declarations of interest
oh thank you um i'll now turn to
item three bc stroke 221 stroke seven
to confirm the minutes of the annual
meeting held on the 25th of may
2021 for accuracy only
are there any issues with accuracy
thank you very much could i have a
proposal please
council award accounts and uh second of
please
council mel vasey please thank you
i will now ask the corporate manager
governance and civic office to conduct
the electronic vote
thank you chair councillors the vote is
now open
and we'll show in blue please click on
the blue line to open the vote
thank you
counselor hinton
at this juncture i'd like to move a
motion without notice
that council council procedure rule 1.4
will be suspended in relation to the
emotional notice on the agenda
proposed by myself cancer procedure rule
1.4
which i have moved to suspend in
relation to my motion on the agenda
effectively requires any motion to add
to the council's procedural
vote for the next meeting of the full
council
this situation not suspending this rule
would mean that the motion in my name
would have to wait two months before
being voted upon
while for complex and lengthy amendments
to the procedural rule
it may well be helpful for the extra
amount of time to consider the proposed
changes
does not seem necessary or proportionate
to have to wait
two extra months time for my motion to
be voted upon
given that it proposes only a very minor
amendment and relates only to
[Music]
asked at future cancer light
of transparent
democracy i think it's important that
we debate this motion as soon as
possible
and i ask for a second
yes so we're actually in the vote for
that we haven't declared on that yet so
um when we get to when we get to your
motion
that will be the time that you move to
suspend them and ask me to speak so
okay sorry okay thank you
thank you jen can i just say that
um we have um 27 votes for and one
abstention for the minutes
so that is carried thank you
now i like to go to item three bc 21
strokes
i've done that one um bc 21 stroke eight
announcements from the chairman and the
leader
they are for noting and
and they are all as far as i am
concerned as chairman
they are listed there of myself and the
vice chair on our events that we
attended
mr chairman now ask the leader for his
kevin having invited me to speak earlier
and i've been and being told that it had
to wait until after the result of the
minutes had been
announced uh can i take my voters
without motion
without notice to be um
valid and ask for a second before it so
we can take it on the vote or is it just
being ignored
now you're not being at all um
counseling tonight i'd just like to go
through the list of
of the procedure that we've we've
followed for four years and that's
with the with the list that we are
looking at that's why it's called a
motion without notice
would you believe it thank you chairman
um chairman it's entirely your
discretion whether you wish to take
this motion without notice immediately
or whether you would actually like to
take it
and perhaps a more appropriate point in
the agenda which would be directly ahead
of councillor hinton's motion
um it's at your discretion claire
whether you want to proceed with that
motion without
notice now or or wait until a bit later
in this evening's proceedings
uh council theory are you interviewing
that you can't hear i
cannot i can hear you now i could not
hear
councillor hinton's what he was asked
him for
i i heard the bit about you wanted a
second though but i don't know what you
want a second or two
so perhaps you can speak clearly this
thing behind me was playing up
[Music]
cameron gavin my answer
counselor beers
yes thank you thank you councillor
hinton yes we'll take your
motion now thank you uh then
in which case uh i asked for a second of
my motion
to suspend council cathedral rule 1.4
which is
thank you very much
chairman for clarity would it assist
members if i
um just clarify the motion that's been
proposed by councilman
seconded by councillor maybe so the
motion which is valid as a motion
without notice is to suspend one of the
council procedure rules
the council procedural that's being
suspended
is 1.4 which falls in the introduction
part of the council procedure rules
and states that any motion including a
motion received on notice
or proposition to add to vary or revoke
these council meeting procedure rules
shall when proposed and seconded stand
adjourned without discussion
to the next ordinary meeting of the
council
so the proposal is to suspend 1.4
to enable the discussion of the motion
that appears later on your agenda
chair i would just say that obviously at
your discretion you've decided to allow
the
the uh debate and the vote on that
motion in any case this evening
however the council voting on this
motion without notice
does tidy it up if you like so that
you've got a clear intention of the
council
as well of of their desire to to vote on
councillor hinton's motion
which appears later in the agenda
councillor authy the effect of that
is that the motion will be put debated
if i can just come in at this stage i'm
conscious just reading the room and
reading a few faces i'm not convinced
everybody understood
what's being proposed or can hear
yeah so councillorthy was just
confirming that if this motion is passed
it means that
when you then come on to deal with
councillor hinton's motion which is on
the papers
and that you will be able to debate it
vote and deal with it today
if you don't pass this additional motion
it will sim the motion on the papers
from councillor hinton will simply be
passed over
to a future meeting which is council
hinton's concern so without wishing to
lead members
it would seem eminently sensible to vote
in favor of councillor hinton's
motion at this point which enables you
to deal with the business
in one go rather than spread it out over
two meetings i hope that clarifies
partly
we'll go straight to the vote for this
but uh we'll just wait for
the governor's officer to put it in
[Music]
coffee
should be there now and it should be
showing in blue
so if you would like to place your voice
thank you
[Music]
yeah it's the wrong thing that's that's
not sorry
oh counselor buzz me um
just before we vote on this the
implication would be that we
questions would be allowed at the annual
general meeting is that my understanding
yes
no sorry not of voting on this
what your or the subsequent uh votes
which you're nowhere near on the agenda
yet then if you vote in favor of it it
would allow
questions to be put at the annual
general meeting yes
that's correct so the next annual
general meeting will be
may next may um so there's no rush
to some extent i would suggest that we
don't do this
we put it to the constitution working
group the group that's there for this
very purpose
and they bring it back to the next
council or the council after that
thank you
mr chairman on a point of order um
i have already voted and there you've
come in at the 11th hour given another
point you've done the wrong thing peter
you voted on the wrong thing to agree
the motion
uh received from councillor hinton's got
in front of me
if i can just come in and explain
councillors unfortunately we just had a
slight administrative era where the
incorrect vote was opened up for you to
use
that vote has been closed any votes cast
will be wiped so when we come to that
vote later on the agenda
it will be fresh and start from a clean
slate
the vote that you actually need to
participate in is about
the suspension of council procedure rule
1.4
and i'm just waiting for colleagues to
indicate that that vote is available for
you
at this stage there should be no debate
on items further on in the agenda this
is purely a vote
as to whether or not the council wishes
to suspend that procedural
thank you chair thank you emily that
vote is now
showing to agree to the motion not on
notice
received from councillor hinton that's
down
under um if you scroll down you will see
that in blue
now and the other vote has been
cancelled so if you could
vote on that line in blue that would be
great thank you
come up the wrong one again
motion on notice yeah yeah and then
under that it says to agree to the
motion not on note
so there's two votes there now so you're
going to go for the one which is in blue
the other one is not
going to work at the moment so if you
were voting not only
if you could vote to agree the motion
which has been received
not on notice that is what you're voting
for
i know
the motion to to agree to the motion not
unnoticed received from councillor
hinton is this
the one that you're requesting that we
suspend rule
yes please um
1.4 on the constitution all right so
i'll go into that one
chair that has been carried i didn't
thank you yeah thank that notice
has uh been carried thank you
all right can i get back what do i need
to get back to the
yeah right
right um we'll now go on
apologies to to you members
um we'll go back to bc 21 8
i've given my uh comments for
noting only and i'll now turn to council
award
have you anything to report
i know that many of you are unhappy that
we are yet again having to hold a
council meeting here at worsted
and i do share your frustration whilst
we welcome the relaxation of social
distancing measures
as we all begin to learn to live with
covid we are however mindful of the
current levels of local
and national infection and therefore the
need to remain vigilant and protect
against the spread of infection still
remains
in the workplace which includes council
meetings there is specific government
guidance which
we still need to adhere to some councils
in suffolk have cancelled their meetings
this month as a result of the challenge
of adhering to that guidance
we've taken a proportionate approach
this democracy needs to not just
be done but seen to be done we're
therefore meeting to deal with motions
questions and urgent items of business
but in order to do so we have had to
hold the meeting here again
whilst it is great to be meeting in
person we will of course return to
endeavour house
once the relevant guidance permits and
we should be back to normal for our next
meeting in september
i think we are all surprised and pleased
that there has been an unexpected
quick turnaround in the rising infection
numbers of the delta variant in this
third wave of covert
this gives further optimism that the
vaccination program coupled with a
pragmatic response by the public in
continuing to
observe some restrictions and protection
measures are really bringing the virus
under long-term control
here in baber cases have also started to
decline in recent days
and while still the highest in the
county they are below the east of
england and national figures
infections are still mostly in the 15 to
29 age group but it is worrying that
this group
is showing increasing resistance to
campaigns to get vaccinated
it does seem that relentless online
disinformation especially the
particularly pernicious claim that the
vaccines affect fertility
is having an impact even among the
well-educated
we counselors must do our best to
support the government's message and
constantly promote the benefits and
efficacy of the vaccination program for
all age groups
on behalf of the local outbreak
engagement board i urge continued
continued caution and the need for all
of us to jab
test and protect the rest we should
still choose to wear masks
use sanitizers and respect social
distancing in the words of our soundbite
this summer we need to spread kindness
not covered
although it's been happening over the
past two months since we last met and
you will have all seen the announcements
that demonstrate that we are delivering
on all of our strategic priorities
i am particularly pleased about the
shortlisting of the housing solutions
team for a national community heroes of
the year award by the local government
magazine
the municipal journal this is a
fitting recognition for heather tucker
who has done so much for us and will be
leaving soon to be the head of housing
at east
council she goes with our heartfelt
thanks and best wishes for the future
the other announcement i am excited
about is the innovate local program to
support business innovation on our high
streets
business owners who would like to
showcase their business on a market saw
can be part of the pilot innovate local
scheme at hadley and stone market
they will benefit from a free pitch at
either market for a set period
along with advice training and support
before and after the pilot
the first participant in hadley has
already signed up and will start trading
on 6th of august
in addition to the market source the
program will be opening an innovation
hub
in i and a pop-up hub in sudbury later
this year
these hubs will provide small businesses
with access to workspace
mentoring program as well as advice and
training the hubs have been delivered in
partnership with the innovation labs and
businesses will also be able to use
innovation labs collective working space
based in stone market
our carbon reduction management and
biodivers diversity action plans are
underway with funding approved for a new
water filtration system at the
kingfisher pool
biodiversity mapping and a tree canopy
survey
we have also just agreed to the
completion of the project to replace
street lights in the district with leds
replacing the remaining 14 units and
this will be funded from the climate
change and biodiversity reserve
and finally it is great news that our
districts will host the final stage of
this year's women's tour on the 9th of
october
the world's top female cyclists will
pass through along melford sudbury the
walden fields bilderson
washington flying station and stone
market on their way to the finish line
in felix stone
well that was going to be my final
announcement but hot off
the press today i have just been
informed that the 2019-20 accounts were
signed off yesterday
there have been audit delays outside of
our control which have affected other
local authorities as well
but we have finally got there thank you
[Music]
chairman
even aren't we i said we're very proud
to have it going through glemson as well
thank you mr chairman um would the lead
very kindly
um email all counsellors um
his report please because i only have to
ask every side not here
at all thank you oh didn't the pace
yes
other points of clarification to be
raised
thank you i don't think there's any
friends on
um item six
item six members quick i don't
you might need to point that narrow but
also i don't know
time
thank you members questions uh on item
six questions by the public in
accordance with council procedure rules
i refer to the question in the table
papers
we have received a question from mr
morelli
to counsel a halt cabinet member for
economic growth
mr morelli could you please come forward
to the lectern and ask your question
thank you on the 5th of july 2021
the baba cabinet debated a report on
bellevue park in sudbury
the recommendations from which the
council will consider today
at agenda item 11a of today's meeting
prior to that cabinet debate councillor
lindsay asked a question
regarding the contract the council has
agreed with churchill retirement living
in his question councillor lindsay
pointed out that baby district council
will not be paid by churchill until and
unless
churchill is granted planning permission
for the works it intends to carry out
in addition councillor lindsay stated
that under the contract
agreed with churchill favor does not
have to start work on the retaining wall
until that time
councilor lindsay therefore asked why
money to pay for the retaining wall
needed to be borrowed
before churchill receives planning
permission should that occur
and therefore before the contract with
churchill completes
and the council is paid in response
council holt stated that borrowing money
in advance of contract completion was
necessary because
to use council halt's own words if baba
does quote not start this work prior to
completion
of the churchill contract baba will have
insufficient
time to meet the contract obligations to
start on the site within three months
i therefore understand that in essence
babe has signed up to a contract
that requires it to borrow money before
churchill has even received planning
permission
for its intended development again
should that occur
could i therefore ask councillor holt in
his position as cabinet member for
economic growth
if i'm correct in the understanding that
i've described
why was the contract agreed that
necessitated boy baba borrowing money
prior to the said contracts completion
from which funding is intended to be
provided
especially given that there is no
guarantee churchill will receive
planning permission for its development
at all
thank you can i ask councillor holt
the member for uh cabinet member for
economic growth to
respond please
no yeah yeah oh yeah okay
the ford funding element proposed is
predominantly to carry out design work
pre-build contract site studies and
other work to enable construction
to start on site within the time scales
proposed in the contract
with the purchaser
thank you councillor hall supplement mr
morelli have you a supplementary
question
yes and can i just say that it needs to
have
uh a question on the
on the question you first asked and this
must be dir
directly related and must not be
preceded by a statement
must not be preceded by statement
um the initial version of the cabinet
report
um had a risk uh with an impact level of
four catastrophic however
that risk was downgraded prior to the
cabinet meeting
uh to read three bad um email
correspondence
mr morelli i need i'm afraid um if i
just asked my question it'd make no
sense because it needs the context
otherwise
it makes no sense
is it all right to make a brief
statement beforehand to provide context
to the question
i want a direct question mr merrily
please
um there is no provision
within council procedural 12
point eight that requires that there be
no statement beforehand
to provide context
i require a question on the
supplementary we've always
in my time always work with that and
therefore
when i previously asked a question at um
the last meeting which was two meetings
ago i was permitted to
make a brief statement beforehand to
proceed my supplementary question
so i don't understand why this has
changed
if you can't ask the question i would
suggest that
i would suggest that you relate it
directly to what you've already asked
please okay
so my original question was on bellevue
um the report of which the
recommendations from which is before the
council today
um again as i've said uh the risk impact
was previously rated as four
catastrophic and is now three bad
email correspondence um has not fully
ascertained
uh why the risk that was previously
described as four catastrophic does not
still exist and has been removed so
could i therefore ask councillor halt
um if you could provide me with a full
and complete explanation
as to why the risk was downgraded from
four catastrophic to three bad
thank you councillor hall would you like
to respond please
i think what i'd like to say is that in
the earlier draft report
it had an incorrect incorrect risk
rating
as this was an administrative error
so the risk was not downgraded
thank you councillor holt for that
response and i can move on to the next
item
uh questions by councillors in
accordance with council procedure rules
i refer to the questions in the table
papers
i would like to invite councillor hinton
to ask
ask his questions
are we working again here yet no can't
hear me
oh yeah done are we working now
yes i think so
[Music]
my first question based on based on the
secretary of state's
decision on the matter of swayedal
council versus queen of states limited
and mulberry estates sitting board
limited concerning the conditions and
matters
of their planning decision concerning in
particular climate change
what is the relevance of this council's
decision to clear a climate emergency in
respect of any meaningful actions
that we can take to help achieve any
result
and how can the cabinet's decision to
spend thousands of pounds on an audit of
trees in the district have any relevance
thank you i would like to
invite councillor malvosi to cabinet
member for environment
to respond thank you very much chairman
the climate emergency the world faces is
so immense and thoroughly entwined
that in every decision we make as human
beings
it will not be solved solely by planning
legislation
it will be tackled by each and every one
of us
you me our communities our businesses
all taking responsibility for the
emissions that we create
and doing what we can to reduce them
of course our emerging local plan pushes
us further towards this goal
and this council will continue to push
further
where we can just like we're doing in
other areas
moving our fleet to hydro-treated
vegetable oil
decarbonizing our leisure center
buildings
piloting a water filtration system at
kingfisher leisure
to reduce water usage and reduce energy
consumption
building a solar carport moving to green
energy tariffs investing in energy
efficiency initiatives for our council
homes
creating an energy prospectus for
suffolk
and focusing on sustainable travel
these are just a few and in answer to
your
second the second part of your question
however this council also recognizes
that the increasing
pace with which natural habitat is being
lost
that it too has now become a
biodiversity emergency
we set up a biodiversity task force in
july 2020
and while it would have been easy for
the group to consider many ambitions
they acknowledge that the focus should
be on achievable actions
those actions over which they have
control or
influence these centered on
understanding and
enhancing the wildlife corridors
enhancing the councils
are boring cultural have difficulty with
that one
environmental resources and expertise
trees provide a multitude of benefits
to us all personally and environmentally
while some of the social and aesthetic
benefits can be difficult to measure
there are tools which help quantify and
value some of the environmental benefits
provided by trees
including carbon storage carbon
sequestration
storm water reduction and don't we need
it now
pollution pollution removal but we have
limited data
on the number of trees that we have on
babyland
the current estimate is somewhere in the
region of ten thousand trees
and even less information about the
trees that cover the rest of the
district
our tree officers are managing an
incredible
natural capital asset but until now
we've had no way of quantifying what the
combined asset is worth
in terms of financial value or what the
trees are providing
us with an ecosystem service
the tree canopy survey work will give us
a complete picture
while also making the information easily
available
for all to see and understand
thank you uh councillor malvesi
councillor hinton have you a
supplementary question have mr chairman
um will the council be writing to the
prime minister to declare that to
declare that his ambition of zero
carbon zero by 2030 is unobtainable
given the restrictions in place on local
efforts to improve carbon efficiency
in planning decisions in particular and
the willful destruction of trees which
move and store carbon dioxide
and when you're referring to trees on
council land
there is a piece of council land in my
village with a tree on it
which the council is proposing to chop
down so that they can give the piece of
land to the housing association and
it'll be easier for them to cut the
grass
now if that's not willful destruction of
a carbon soak i don't know what is
old trees cannot be replaced with the
same efficiency
of carbon reduction by new whips no
matter how many are planted
there's been items in the press recently
about net zero
buildings council to help curb housing
emissions counselor hinton i think
building
your question i think you've asked your
question if building regulations were
changed
the planning committee could ask people
to put in heat source pumps solar panels
and more carbon of climate effective
measures
thank you councillor hinton uh council
melvacey would you like to respond to
that
thank you very much um there are
essentially two parts to your question
if i'm not mistaken one is building
regulations
which we as a council cannot write
we would love to rewrite them but we
will definitely lobby
and it's currently
happening that the building regulations
do come through with an amendment
but your second question was that you've
got a tree and threatened to be
demolished
and i would suggest that you email me
with the details of that
situation and i will take it up and see
if i can save the tree
okay thank you thank you councilman
marvoti
i now invite councillor hinton to ask
his second second
question please thank you mr chairman
is it correct that the joint legal teams
have contracted out the negotiation of
s-106 planning notices
to an independent company and if so when
and who conducted the competitive
tendering process
thank you i now like to ask
uh invite councillor arthur cabinet
member for planning to respond
the answer to your question is no
negotiation of section 106 plan notice
has
not been contracted out to an
independent company
sometimes our legal service outsources
the drafting
of section 106 agreements to external
solicitors
due to resource issues such as when
other urgent matters need to be
prioritized
if section 106 agreements are outsourced
there is no cost to the authority so
there is no requirement to undertake any
tendering process
thank you councillor arthi council
hinton would you
like to ask a supplementary question yes
please mr chairman
uh is a council aware that there has
been a transfer of legal expertise
from the joint legal team to the outside
contraction contractor as a result of
this action
and is the council aware that the fees
charged
for negotia for producing these 106
agreements
which local builders are forced to pay
have increased by 50 percent
making smaller builders in particular
less competitive in the market
and reducing the choice for our future
and existing residents
thank you thank you thank you
um i can't answer what the whole of
council are aware of
i'm afraid but um if he's asking me am i
aware that the costs associated
um with the drafting of these agreements
by outsourced
solicitors is higher than it would be if
it was done
in-house the answer is yes i am aware
thank you thank you cloud salathi um
and i would now like to uh invite
council dawson to ask her a question
please
resident sorry can you hear me yes a
local resident received planning
permission for the erection of a single
story rear extension
for an application registered march 2020
the development was permitted on
condition it was begun no later than the
expiration of 18 months from the date
of the permission uh i'd like to ask
count sarathy
can you advise if there have been any
amendments due to covid
19 to section 91 of the town and
planning
country planning act as amended that can
give applicants
relief from this time scale
if you could please clarify because i
understand residents applications
have to be reapplied and submitted again
when the application expires
thank you councillor dawson councillor
arthi
would you like to respond please yeah
thank you chairman and thank you
councillor dawson for the question
um i know that i'm only required to read
my written answer word for word
but this is a question that refers to a
specific
and had you given me the details of that
i would have been able to give an answer
to the specific
so the answer to the first part of your
question is
no but the business and planning act
2020
did provide temporary modification to
the town and country planning act 1990
and the planning listed buildings and
conservation areas
act of 1990 to enable certain
permissions which had lapsed
or were due to lapse during 2020
to be extended this was in recognition
of the effect coronavirus has had on
planning and construction
and in particular in particular the
delays around commencement of new
development
i'll give you the details of that
unimplemented planning permissions with
time limits for
implementation collapsing between the
19th of august 2020
and the 31st of december 2020
were automatically extended to the 1st
of may
2021 unimplemented planning permissions
with time limits for implementation
which lapsed between the 23rd of march
2020 and the 19th of august
2020 also had time limits extended to
the 1st of may 2021
provided an additional environmental
approval process
was followed outline permissions were
also extended in the same way
whilst the deadline for submission of
reserve matters which would have been
due between the 23rd of march
2020 and the 31st of december 2020
was extended to the 1st of may 2021
the legislation only applied to these
specific periods and there has been no
change to the statutory time period for
the commencement conditions that we
apply
the answer to the second part of your
question is yes
if no work has been done that
constitutes implementation of a consent
another application would be required on
expiry
or the planning permission will lapse
thank you thank you council arthi
councillor
dawson would you like a supplementary
question please
um yes i would actually um well my
supplementary question then is
in february 2019
the acting chief planning officer
recommended planning consent
hold just a moment mr council dawson
could we get the vote can you hear
sorry in february 2019
the acting chief planning officer
recommended planning consent be
authorized
to grant listed building consent for the
baba offices at cork's lane
subject to the number one condition
stated a standard time limit
this is a major condition put forward by
myself at the time
which was the building works would
commence no later than 18 months
from the date of permission granted
um it has not commenced work within the
time scale being june 11
21 and this has been confirmed
by council award and minuted at recent
minute meetings
therefore i think in light of this can
you confirm that the cork's lane
development
will not be exempt from breaching a
major condition
as no amendment has been made under the
section 91 of the town and country act
and i think now as we have a rainbow
cabinet i'd like to see
councillor arthi as the pac as the
cabinet member for planning
and council plum as chair of the
planning committee
please can you give a personal assurance
to take responsibility for ensuring this
application
will be resubmitted and returned to
committee as soon as possible
as all other applications from local
residents will have to be
uh any further delay will cause further
financial costs in respect to the
security etc which
have already exceeded probably three
hundred thousand
since we vacated in 2015.
thank you council of dawson council
would you like to respond
um i i can't really answer that question
here and now
the reason being that i will have to
check the date of the decision
i will have to check the conditions
attached to that decision and
i will have to check the date of expiry
so
i can give you a written answer after
the well not not immediately after the
meeting but out of meeting
thank you thank you thank you councillor
arthur
all right um
response i think would be quite useful
thank you
all right yep that one we're done with
counselor arthur
a response to all yeah thank you um
and i'd like to now to turn to um item
eight
overview and scrutiny committee report
and i'd like to invite councilman
mclaren to introduce the paper bc 21
stroke 9
which is for noting thank you
can you hear me no
no
now
right yeah
thank you chair and members
you have in front of you uh the report
from
the weber overview and scrutiny
committee
however um before i invite any questions
i need to apologize for a footnote that
i should have added
at the bottom of the report in relation
to the meeting that was held
in june uh and that's an oversight on my
part and i'm sorry it's not there
in a formal uh
presentation but hopefully it will be
recorded in the minutes of this meeting
uh you need to be advised that the
meeting on that day
ended at 1 27 p.m as the baby
overview and scrutiny committee became
inquired
and so all items that were remaining
on the agenda were transferred and
considered at the july meeting
if you wish to see the details of that
meeting
obviously the minutes are on
mod.gov and on the website
so if anybody's got any questions i'd be
happy to take them
thank you very much thank you council
mclaren
the members will note please that
any uh any uh question
or not questions as such that must be
for
um yeah sorry
clarification yeah clarification only so
any of the
uh questions uh any of the the comments
made
to council mclaren must be for
clarification thank you
are there any
oh sorry councillor lindsey
is this for clarification clarification
yes yes yes um
it and it may be that i i quite
understand
if council mclaren cannot clarify this
but
but i think it needs to be asked anyway
because the the
the item on cifco you mention in your
report
um uh that i did watch that on
youtube and um there was a question
about
what happened with cifco are withholding
1.5 million pounds in interest payments
from us over the next three years
and question was asked about when do we
get it back and what guarantee
we have that we get it back and
the officer gave an answer but i didn't
really understand the answer
um there appears to be no guarantee that
we'll get it back
and and it something about being
converted to debt
but i may have got that wrong i i i it
may be that i need
the officer to come back on that i don't
i don't know
thank you thank you ken yeah that's wise
counselor lindsay
i think uh clients council mclaren would
not have those
answers to to clarify that
so ask the officers thank you
if that is all oh yeah
sorry council dawson is this
clarification
sorry is this a clarification
of the over scrutiny well it's just one
i'd like to make a comment about one of
the points on here i was on the
scrutiny that day um
that i think needs addressing and
clarification to members
in the council here is that acceptable
couldn't hear that i'd like to seek
clarification i was on the overview and
scrutiny and i think there's a point
here
um a 1.5 of the overview and scrutiny
that ought to be brought to the members
attention here that's on here
[Applause]
1.5 says and they ought to be an
increased use of tasks and finish groups
to be adopted by the committee
and um i sort of felt that on
on on that particular day the issue was
brought up and all babies members voted
against it but we were actually outvoted
by mid suffolk
and the result of that we've got to go
away and find members to sit on
particular task groups
and i just sort of feel that maybe going
forward members
certainly on both sides ought to be
aware of
you know these joint overview and
scrutiny meetings
um how the chair is perhaps going to
deal with these issues on
the the one that came up okay thank you
councillor dawson councilman
mclaren thank you councillor
uh dawson can i just clarify with you
that 1.5 related to the previous meeting
and you are discussing about well the
second meeting yes
yes where we had a split vote in
relation to a task and finished group
um i
i believe that task and finish groups
should be very
focused and benefit residents
and at the end of the exercise
they should be we shouldn't be saying so
what
i think we as a
committee joint committee should
um think carefully
about creating a task and finish group
and you're quite right we the the joint
committee was split
on that vote at the last meeting
is that as that answer the question
thank you thank you
because going forward council dawson
yeah can you please
come through the chair sorry
i think that was a good explanation for
councillor mclaren
and i think that's answered the
clarification there thank you
not quite
right now other clarifications i'd like
to move on to um
item nine councillor appointments
and nine a to consider whether
to confirm or not the vote of no
confidence in the chairman of licensing
regulatory committee and commit council
is asked to consider whether
to confirm or not the vote of no
confidence in the chairman of licensing
and regulatory committee proposed by
councillor maybe
and seconded by council nun at a license
and regulatory
committee held on the 11th of june 2021
i would like to invite the monitoring
officer to introduce this item you chair
um can i just check that everyone can
hear me as has been the
the custom this evening to check oh that
was a bit of feedback
is everyone okay thank you
so in accordance with committee
procedural 4.1
a vote of no confidence in the chairman
of the licensing and regulatory
committee was passed at the meeting of
the committee
on the 11th of june 2021
the motion was carried by five votes to
two representing more than two-thirds of
the committee members present
at the meeting three committee members
were not present
committee procedure rule 4.2 requires
that the full council now determines
whether or not
to confirm the committee's vote of no
confidence
this is a vote by simple majority
if the council confirms the vote of no
confidence
councillor newman will be removed from
the presid position of chairman of
licensing and regulatory committee
and the council will be required to
elect a new chairman of the committee
if the council rejects the vote of no
confidence
councillor newman will remain as
chairman of the committee
chairman i would now like to provide
some guidance if i may to councillors on
this vote
as this process arises so infrequently
and i want to be sure that all
councillors understand the voting
process
councillors if you agree with the vote
of no confidence and want to elect a new
chairman of the licensing and regulatory
committee
you should vote for the motion
if you do not support the vote of no
confidence and want counsellor newman to
remain as chairman of the committee
you should vote against the motion thank
you chairman
thank you i would now
ask the corporate manager governance and
civic office
to conduct the electronic vote thank you
chair
that vote um to confirm the vote of no
confidence in the chairman of license
and regulatory committee
is now showing in blue if you'd like to
cast your votes please cancel us thank
you
councillor lindsay can i take your vote
please
that has voted okay thank you
councillor melviezi can i take your vote
please or is it still going through
thank you and cancer beer i'm still
waiting for yours
okay can i take it manually then please
again
and cancel a beer oh yes
okay
answer beer can i take your vote please
oh no sorry it's just come through
okay so the voting is for
the vote of no confidence 12 votes and
against
the vote of no confidence is 16 votes
so that vote of no confidence was
lost thank you yeah thank you
yeah the mo the
vote is lost thank you i've now
gone to our next item which is um
9c appointment to outside body
suffolk joint emergency planning policy
panel
could i have a proposal to appoint
council ward as the council's
representative on the
suffolk joint oh sorry counselor hinton
can i first clarify whether there's a
point
can't hear you planning
a word can't hear can't hear
can i confirm whether or not the
candidate for this appointment has to
have completed the joint emergency
of the emergency planning colleges in
york's
training program to qualify for this
position
um thank you councillor i'm not aware
that they do
know they will undertake some training
but i'm not aware what
if it's the training it's the chairman
it's just obviously some
some conflict here because certainly
when i had that
post about eight years ago
i had to have taken the training before
i could take up the position and i
believe councilman mabry's in a similar
position
oh have you heard the refreshing council
well i will clarify that and come back
to council award if he's appointed
tonight
um right so could i have a
proposal to appoint council walter
council representative the
suffolk joint emergency planning policy
panel thank you
councillor arthur i'll propose council
award and if he needs training i suggest
he should have it
uh councillor john osborne i can't mr
chairman and also now in council award
he will make sure he's very familiar
with the subject that he's dealing with
thank you he's good at dealing with
disasters aren't you john
i will now ask the corporate managed
governance and civic office to conduct
the electronic vote
thank you chair that vote is now showing
in blue if councillors would like to
place their vote thank you
chair that is 23 4 and 5 abstentions
so that is carried thank you thank you
very much
um it's very remiss of me and i i do
apologize
but i should have declared that
councillor mark
newman is duly appointed as the chair of
license in the regulatory committee
thank you i'm sorry mark
9d to note the following appointments
council is asked to note the
appointments to committees as detailed
on the agenda oh council plum
i just want to absolutely clarify that
the
new member on the planning committee has
had
all the up-to-date training that the
rest of the committee has reserved
has received in the last two years
and if he hasn't when will it be done so
that we can have him as an active member
of the planning committee
thank you chair i'm
i'm not i'm not aware of the chair um
can i just come in there so
um councillor barra will be appointed to
planning committee he has
undertaken planning training in the past
but we will get that done
as soon as possible and definitely
before he sits on the next committee
thank you thank you
what do i need to go on to next
proceed on the agenda for item 10
motions on notice and i'd like to
ask uh to consider the motion of notice
received from
council hinton
council maybe
not to have to agree agree that
councillor melanie barrett
um will be um
joining us on over scrutiny or is that
just
just taken as read please check can i
just comment i'm not aware of that
sorry i can just confirm that because
the um appointments were notified to the
warranty
the monitoring officer she has used her
um
delegations to be able to point in
between so council are just noting those
two appointments
for outside bodies it's a council
appointment when we do need to vote so
that's the difference thank you
um may i come back mr chairman
yes councilman thank you at the annual
meeting we had to agree
the makeup of the um
of the individual committees and those
they're in
so i'm a bit flummoxed
i think that's the word that the
monitoring officer has just agreed this
i have nothing against
either councillor councillor barrett's
but i just think we should do this
as a matter of procedure please thank
you
councillor i'm sorry emily would you
like to respond
thank you chairman yes i can clarify for
for councillors that this process has
all been followed correctly
under part two of the constitution
responsibility of functions
i do have a delegation to implement
changes to committee places between
council meetings
and for any council that wishes to look
it up or any member of the public uh
listening that would like to look it up
it is
paragraph 2.7 under council
responsibilities
and there is a note that states any
changes to membership of a committee or
subcommittee
can be implemented by the monitoring
officer following a request by the
relevant group leader and notified to
the next available council meeting
this is the first available council
meeting following the
request from the conservative group
leader to make the published
changes to the committee places and
just to to confirm further there is no
change
to the political balance of the
committee which is something that has to
come forward to council to be agreed
so that's where councillors may have
recognized this kind of thing actually
coming forward
to be voted on in the past thank you
chairman
thank you emily um right if i
go forward now to the motions on notice
of beer sorry
sorry to prolong this but i think
councillor
maybe does have a point um whilst
the councillor uh manonie barrett on the
um um overview and scrutiny committee
and you're saying that this uh was done
out of meat and
by delegation powers why did we have to
vote then on
councillor simon barrett being put on
the planning committee
why couldn't that have been taken out of
um
under delegation powers you know why is
there two different rules here
chairman we haven't voted on either of
the amendments to the committee places
right as described by the deputy
monitoring officer
the outside body places do have to be
voted on so the position that john
council award was was elected to just
just moments ago
that does require a vote because there's
no delegation in place but we haven't
voted on
either of the council of barrett's
appointments so
right then why weren't we told that uh
councillor melanie barrett was going to
be appointed to the overseer and
kootenai
committee because i think that's the
whole point
thank you just for the avoidance of
doubt those two
places and the names are published on
the agenda
right i'd like to move forward now with
the emotions on notice
to consider the emotional notice
received from counselor hinton
councillor hinton would you like to move
your motion
the motion can you can you get near the
mic again you've heard it probably
feedback
it's not peppermint flavored though
the motion itself is uh within the
papers for the committee and i don't
propose to go over all of that
what i would just like to amplify is the
fact that
the council is in danger of losing the
confidence of the public
by not being open and transparent in its
democratic dealings with the public
we've had a fiasco just recently over
the audit of electors
where it was being done electronically
having warned everybody to watch out for
bogus emails and i'm afraid the
chief executive's response that it was
publicized on
the website and on twitter uh
it's not very satisfactory when you
consider that not everybody's on twitter
i'm certainly not on it and i won't go
on it
i certainly do not sit there riveted to
the baba website on the off chance that
something
might pop up and when our own audit has
said that only 60 percent of the
population of baba have access to a
computer
then that makes a little bit of a joke
of that as a communication
medium so we are in danger of alienating
the public
and making them feel that they're they
are just
cash cows if you like supplying money to
the council
it is also relevant to state that i
don't think that's appropriate
counseling
2016 and i haven't gone any further back
than that
questions from the public were allowed
and on the agenda
for the annual council meetings
since then i would i would acknowledge
that we have reduced the number of
meetings
and that's probably where the change in
terms of questions from members of the
public
at the annual council meeting was
slipped in
um but that in actual fact makes it even
more
important that we reinstate it because
there are even fewer opportunities
for members of the public to ask all the
questions of the council
during the course of a year now we keep
saying we haven't gotten
we've got uh we're producing a number of
council meetings because we haven't got
enough business etc
well if we make sure that the members of
the public don't actually want to get
involved because they
uh we make it too difficult etc then i'm
not surprised
it is a if we're going to be open and
democratic about these things
we have to reinstate this provision
and change the council procedure rule 12
to make the asking of questions by
members of the public
and councillors at the annual council
meeting a formality
on the agenda i would ask you
i would ask you to support this motion
could i have a second to please
counselor owen thank you
thank you i'll reserve my right at the
end to speak thank you
thank you very much council award
[Music]
although in here can you hear me now
yeah yeah i don't have much objection to
this motion
in fact no objection at all um although
it is somewhat irregular for a motion to
be written by a member of the public
however it is far too wordy um i believe
less is more for such a simple request
such as this
it really needs to be short snappy and
to the point for maximum impact
and moreover chairman emotion should not
include the details of changes to the
constitution which is a matter for
either the constitution working group
or the monitoring officer depending on
how substantive the changes are
i therefore like to propose the
following amended motion
this motion proposes that this council
allows questions from councillors and
members of the public at the annual
meeting at the moment questions have to
be held over until the next ordinary
meeting following the annual meeting
which can sometimes interfere with
democratic accountability because
questions may no longer be current
and thereby lose their relevance as this
is a straightforward change to the
constitution
this motion proposes the council
instructs the monitoring officer
to make the appropriate changes to the
annual meeting order of business in the
constitution
and if members would like i can
email the exact text so you've got it in
front of you
thank you council award could i have a
second to please
counselor jan osborne
on the face of it what um council award
said sounds exactly like councillor
hinton's
motion but much shorter is is that right
it sounds as though the effect is
exactly the same
that a member of the public will be able
to ask a question at the annual meeting
but for some reason council awards
amendment
seemed to be much shorter than the
original motion
i think that is correct yep but the
effect is the same
in fact it will be the same okay great
thank you thank you councillor alfie
councillor hinton do you accept this
amendment
no mr chairman the the emotional facing
emotion may seem worthy uh but anybody
who's had a look at the constitution
they will know that it is so worthy that
it is uh
designed i in my opinion uh to allow
people to drive a coach and horses
through it to uh
mean whatever they want to mean i think
that i would like to stick with my own
wording thank you
even though as council board has said
he's effectively
has nothing against it why change it
yeah okay castle ward
the change is is essentially around how
the the constitution is amended
and that it's for either the working
group or the monitoring officer to do
that
and in this instance i'm proposing that
the monitoring officer makes the
appropriate changes to the constitution
rather than being directed by specific
text in the motion
back on that the constitution belongs to
the members
of baba district council not the
constitution
it belongs to the all the members of
baber district council
and any changes have to come back to
this full council anyway
so why don't we just sort this out here
and now why
is some everybody trying to make a meal
of it or trying to bury it in the long
grass yep
i'm sure that's not the intention
if you are not um if you are not uh
approving the amendment or um
then we have to go for debate and that
will be on the amendment
to start with yeah
councillor busby i suspect none of us
have got our constitutions here so it's
going to be very difficult to
identify what words need to be changed
and what don't
i mean surely the simple uh
reason behind this is that we would like
the public
and members to be able to ask questions
at all council meetings
isn't that it yeah can we not rely on
the monitoring officer to make the
amendments to the
constitution that covers that uh
sentiment
i think we can i tend to agree with you
can i ask the monitor
oh councilman mayberry thank you mr
chairman i do have a copy of the
constitution with me
if anybody would like to have a look at
it oh you're such a girlfriend
yeah just yeah
the chairman's just asked me to to
comment on the on the process for
amending the constitution and i'm
grateful to the comments from councillor
busby
um about his confidence in my ability to
amend your constitution
and indeed that is the normal practice
either
amendments are proposed by the
constitution working group and that's
normally if they're quite substantial
amendments or if the council indicates
uh
its will to insert something into the
constitution
it can give me a delegated authority to
then craft the actual provisions of the
constitution
and and make that come alive for example
the provisions that i was asked to draft
draft and insert
to enable the council to meet virtually
during the covert
covert 19 pandemic so so chair um
either route is possible um however it
is customer practice for a change
such as this to be delegated to the
monitoring officer um to put into
practice
fine council award have you anything to
add to uh
monitor office uh from what i i don't
have anything to add from what i've said
and from what the monitoring officers
said uh covers everything quite honestly
um it's a simple and straightforward way
to
to get to get this change made to the
constitution in time for next year's
annual meeting
if nobody else has got comments
counselor well yeah it's no disrespect
at all to councillor hinton
uh to agree with councillors ward and
busby
that the monitoring officer is probably
the best person to put the right words
into our constitution
um for what council hinton is seeking to
achieve here and i think we all we're
all clear what it is
and that is that we can have questions
at the annual council meeting
so i think the amendment is a sensible
one actually i would rather have the
constitution written by a monitoring
officer than
sorry than by councillor hinton
i think oh i don't know about that
council
well based on what the monetary officers
just said about if council decides they
want to insert something into the
constitution
then we can insert this if the wording
needs tweaking a bit then
presumably the monitoring officer can
use her delegated powers to uh tweet the
wording
with that and keep it so that it's
in line if you like with the rest of the
constitution um
i don't see the problem there
councillor haran and then councillor
barrett
chairman can i just ask if our
monitoring officer amends the
constitution surely it then comes back
to
council to agree what she has written is
that correct
like this um if the amendment was
approved
then the discretion is left to me to to
determine the exact wording
but it would be then circulated to all
councillors so it wouldn't come back
again
for further approval um
there wouldn't be a need i would just
simply be acting on the will of the
council
well i think i think chairman i'm happy
for the modern office to do it and if
she doesn't get it right we'll amend it
again let's leave it like that
thank you councillor council barrett um
would i be correct in assuming that um
the
uh leader probably took advice from the
monitor officer for his amendment
uh i think that's probably a fair
assumption councilor barrett
so we probably get a very similar
agreement from the monitor officer
second time round
we might as well just go with the
amendment by the sounds of it yeah
we're coming sorry it might just seem we
go to a vote
so then we can move forward or back
absolutely council parker
thank you yeah la la la okay um can you
hear me right
um i i'm just wondering chairman i think
i'm i think i'm right in saying
that up until 2016 we always had that
option didn't we to vote at um
annual council so if remember yeah if
that's the case if we got
any i mean council must have had a
reason to have changed things
way back when i mean to avoid this sort
of ping-ponging back and forth have we
got have we got any notion of
why it was changed back then well i
haven't i haven't
uh in all the years that i've been on
council i i cannot remember
uh questions coming up at the uh annual
meeting
council emily
um i'm afraid i can't add any detail to
in in response to that question however
i'm sure it'll be logged as as part of
the review of the constitution that was
undertaken in 2016 and then implemented
in 2017
which of course was undertaken by the
constitution working group
thank you are there any other comments
councillor cartondale thank you chad can
i just
ask if this would also apply to
extraordinary meetings
thank you chair sorry we were just
arguing over who got the opportunity to
to respond to that one um extraordinary
meetings are called for a single purpose
so
uh the other kind of procedural matters
that appear on
uh standard agendas don't apply to
extraordinary meetings
so this wouldn't automatically be
inserted into an agenda for an
extraordinary meeting of the council
councilman oh thank you thank you very
much mr chairman
um i'm just going to ask the leader
um whether
[Music]
only just
um i'm just trying to um inquire of the
leader whether he's
put forward an amendment counseling
i understand i understand that
an amendment to emotion means that it
will be
a motion from the uh conservatives
rather than from the opposition
thank you
yeah uh thank you
council busby council creswell
i'm here just have a vote we should just
have a vote um
on the two uh the amendment uh john
councillor hinton's um
proposal and uh council awards proposal
because we all agree that um
that's a good idea um and it's just
just a matter of getting around it
because we all agree that questions
should be allowed at um
annual meetings so we'll just go around
in circles about the same thing
yes well absolutely like council
creswell
and as councillor barrett has already
alluded to
i think we'll go to the vote on the
amendment please
as we've debated most of this already
thank you chair um if you go to the item
to consider the motion
we have now entered to agree the to the
amendment to the motion on notice
proposed by council award
that is now showing in blue for
councillors to place their vote
thank you
[Music]
shouldn't drink so much counselor newman
are you able to vote or can i take
for the amendment okay
okay thank you chair the voting is 24
7 against and one abstention so that
amendment is carried
thank you um and i suggest that the
monitoring officer looks at this
yeah so i need i need now to vote on the
substantive
motion which is as as just pointed out
so can we go to the vote please
24 sorry not 24.
were more than i thought
okay so we're now going to vote on
the um amend the motion as amended by
councillor ward
and that um so it'll be to agree to the
motion on notice received by counts from
councillor hinton
but now um
it belongs to cancer ward as a
substantive motion
so that will now show in blue under that
item
can you just clarify the voting position
yeah
so it see it reads to agree to the
motion on notice
received from councillor hinton but now
including agreed
amendment and that is now in pro
progress
so you're you're voting for the
substantive motion
as tabled by council awards
councillor newman would you like to
place your vote manually
or okay thank you
and councilman we haven't received your
vote are you able to
oh it's just come through okay so that
is 27 votes for
thank you and one abstention
thank you so the substantive motion is
carried
um i've been asked if
we could have a smaller
break by councillor arthur and i think
five minutes would be ample thank you
thank you thank you members i hope
you've had
sufficient time for your comfort break
and i would now like to continue now
with the
recommendations recommendations from
cabinet
11a bellevue park sudbury facilities and
entrance part one chairman uh
i would like to invite councillor ward
to introduce
paper bc 21 stroke 10 and to move the
recommendation
in the report councillors we will
remain in open session unless you wish
to debate the information in the
appendices
b and c relating to the timetable and
costs which are confidential
if this is the case please can you
indicate to me
and i will move to exclude the public
from the meeting whilst the discussion
takes place
thank you council award
can you hear me good on behalf of the
cabinet i'm pleased to present report bc
2110 bellevue park facilities and
entrance
following its approval by cabinet
earlier this month
we're not here to discuss the sale of
part of the site in the house to
churchill retirement living as this is
now a matter for the planning process
and it would not be appropriate for any
of us to comment about it now
similarly we have already decided that
we would like to see a welcoming new
entrance to the park with cafe and
toilet facilities
funded from the sale to churchill both
these decisions were made by cabinet on
11th of march
the purpose of this report is to seek
council's approval
and addition to the capital expenditure
program of the scheme to create a
retaining wall
a new high-quality secure and accessible
park entrance
and new cafe toilet block facilities to
changing places standard
at the bellevue park site in sudbury it
also seeks approval for forward funding
of essential works
by borrowing until the sale to churchill
has completed
we need to join up work streams and
timelines as far as possible to
coordinate works as the two sides of the
site align during development
the forward funding will enable the
council to progress on that basis and
minimize the duration of works and
disruption on site
as stated in option 2.1 b of the report
we will be able to commission a
multi-disciplinary professional team to
support and deliver the stakeholder and
community engagement and detailed design
work
surveys and investigations planning
application
principal contract procurement uh
contractor
procurement liaison with the retirement
living developers professional team
and construction delivery within the
required time frame
these works are likely to cost in the
region of 80 to 100 000 pounds
and although no physical works will
start on site in respect of the
retaining wall
until planning permission is secured by
churchill and the contract with the
council is completed
the pre-work does mean that construction
can commence
in accordance with a program agreed with
the purchaser i.e within three months of
contract completion
to clarify it is this amount for which
we are seeking forward funding
and not the full investment amount of
1.12 million pounds
we have committed to spending all of
that 1.12 million
receipt from churchill on the park to
deliver further improvements in addition
to the new entrance
all of which is in accordance with the
ambitions of the council's approved
vision for prosperity for sudbury
we have also set up a stakeholder group
the bellevue entrance and facilities
group
which includes the town council and
county highways this will enable
stakeholders to have input into the
design
and thereby deliver an acceptable scheme
in planning terms
ensuring that the park will be a great
asset for the town residents and
visitors
this group has been fully informed of
our plans particularly the need for the
retaining wall to separate the two
sites due to the significant difference
in land levels resulting
from our need to excavate to create an
entrance that is compliant with
accessibility requirements
expect to be in a position to present
the detailed design for the entrance and
plans for other improvements to the park
at a public engagement event in the park
in late summer early autumn
appendix a of the report shows a
schematic of what the entrance could
look like from various perspectives
i must stress that it does not imply
designs for any of the elements depicted
the cabinet has reviewed the benefits
against key risks at its meeting on 5th
of july
and is satisfied that the scheme
demonstrates baber's ongoing commitment
to investment in sudbury
and delivers multiple benefits for the
community and visitors
to sudbury and bellevue i would like
therefore to propose the recommendations
of paragraph 3.1 and 3.2
and ask for a seconder
could i have a second of please thank
you council award
councillor hall thank you
can that please and also reserve the
right to speak
thank you council hulk
oh council parker yeah thank you very
much
chairman can everybody uh can everybody
here
um sorry did you want to come in there
mr people
no okay so if i if i may um mr chairman
um it occurs to me that actually the
recommendation in 3.1 and 3.2
are actually two separate items uh and
they are requesting
two different things of council this
evening
um and they're not necessarily
co-dependent in my opinion
so therefore mr chairman it seems to me
to make sense to debate
and then vote on each in turn if that's
possible to do
in in any event i would like to
also propose an amendment to 3.2 at the
appropriate time but in the first
instance
i'd like to inquire as to whether we can
take
each item in in its turn mr chair
thank you have i a seconder for this
that's rath oh counselor hinton
councillor hinton thank you
second
now then yes i i'd like to go straight
to the vote
on on this uh councillor parker
yeah i will take these separately we
don't need to vote on that thank you
um
councillor councillor
council ward sorry council award
just clarify for councillor parker and
others
3.1 is voted against then 3.2
becomes irrelevant and uh we can't
proceed with it
unfortunately we need the um to approve
the capital program
allocation before we can commit to
spending any of that for 3.2
thank you um
councillor parker uh if i can uh if i
can respond to that
um mr chairman i i don't actually think
that that's the case at all
um uh because uh i'm sure it'll come out
in debate that there could well be other
other funding
uh sources available thank you council
parker
um
oh councillor busby thank you jay
i'm somewhat confused as to why we need
3.1 at all uh at the joint
cabinet briefing on the 12th of july it
was reported
that the capital programme we'd
we had four million pounds earmarked to
bellevue
and because we felt we only needed two
million of that we were going to release
the other two million
but we still have two million pounds i
believe in a budget or in a capital
expenditure program why do we need to
approve an additional 1.12 million
um council award
yeah yes uh councillor busby that is in
uh the out turn for the 2020 to 21
financial year
uh that out turn goes to cabinet on
monday
for approval until then that carry
forward does not exist
very well we need any further
clarification
the chairman's just asked me to clarify
the chairman's agreed to take
each of the recommendations separately
and that includes the debate
and the vote on each of the
recommendations so you will start by
asking questions and debating
recommendation 3.1 and then there will
be a vote
and then you will do the same for 3.2
separately
that's clear for everyone everybody
happy
all right then i shall go for questions
then questions on uh
3.1 please having
lindsay thank you chair
i'll just wait for the yeah microphone
too can people hear me now
yeah great
there's a question really if we don't
if this council votes down 3.1
uh will we be in breach of contract
with churchill and can they
sue us
i have an officer here fiona
no it comes just keep talking
um yeah i did um yeah
no so um if you don't approve 3.1
um there could be other ways to fund the
scheme as
council award has pointed out and
actually
um cabinet have already resolved to
divert the capital receipt
so we would need to um work with the
council's financial team to see
how that capital receipt could be
properly allocated if it's not
approved tonight
counselor beer thank you mr chairman
um we're discussing authorizing the
finance financing of this as what we're
referring to in these papers
is that correct and my question
is and i'm tr i won't go
into any details on the pink pages
but my question is regarding the low
wall
the retaining walls the retaining
wall and the temporary retaining wall
my question is if we spend money
now on repairing them
improving them replacing them or
whatever it is that we need to do
and i'm referring more to the one on the
cornered road
although i realize the ones at the front
may have to be
money spent on if we spend money now
a year 18 months down the road are we
likely to find
that this was wasted and we've got to
either knock
down bits of this or or knock a hole
through that
because quite often we agree to these
things and then a year later
oh well we need to knock a bit out of
that so
can i be assured that if we repair
or retain the wall or walls
they're not going to be affected later
by the development
council hold
you all have a um i believe cc which i
sent to savitan council um and i'll draw
your attention to a section in there
and i'll read it out these design plan
and feasibility
works are likely to cost as council
orders already said eighty times a
thousand for the whole scheme
and whilst i can confirm no physical
works will start
on site in respect of the attainment
rule until
plan commission is secured by churchill
and the contract with churchill is
completed
the pre-work which is what we discuss in
here does not mean that construction can
commence
can can commence in accordance with the
program agreed with purchaser ie
three months so it can not the work
don't sorry i'm getting tongue in
the pre-work does not mean the
construction can commence in accordance
with the program
agreed with the purchaser ie within
three months so the focus here
is on the pre-work we're not going to
build a wall we're not going to build an
entrance
this money is to do the pre-work
feasibility designed
for the entrance it's no wall peter
there is no building no construction
gonna commence
until the planning permission if it's
granted
is granted at planning committee and
that's if it's granted yeah
thank you this is feasibility work
pre-work pre-commencement work that will
only kick in
once and if plan and permission is
granted
thank you he's cleared that point thank
you mr chairman yeah thank you
councillor holt
um yeah i'd just
just like to say that probably as all
councils are aware
you can ask as many questions as you
like uh on this
and then uh in debate you'll have one
speak once
on on for three minutes council maybe
thank you mr chairman i have a new
microphone is it working yeah okay yes
we can hear you
thank you very much um i would like
to suggest to councillor halt that it's
a bit
presumptuous of him to say that there
will be no works
taking place because
if um a structural engineer
comes in and actually looks at the site
and declares something
unsafe then there will be construction
work
and this is what concerns me that the
80 to 100 000 which you have declared
to the public will be spent it may well
be an awful lot more
because you don't know what's there you
do not know
what is needed until it is being
reviewed by a proper structural
engineer thank you mr chairman thank you
council hull would you like to
respond to that there are questions but
all i can no work on the entrance or the
wall
will commence until plan of permission
if is granted
if that is the case this is all pre-work
feasibility study work
um fiona have you got anything else to
add to that because
i'm not sure you can add much more to it
to be fair um yeah it's probably worth
just clarifying that the
retaining wall that we are referring to
is the one between
um the site that churchill will be
purchasing
and the new park entrance and that
retaining wall
is required uh largely because
of the levels differences we are seeking
to create
to enable the park entrance um and to
make it
disabled access accessibility um
and to deal with the levels difference
that already exist actually within the
site
may i return thank you mr chairman
may i return you can return yes thank
you
councillor hinton and councillor parker
thank you my return
is i stand by what i have said you do
not know
when you're looking um at a site
particularly since our officer has
declared that there is a difference
in levels that there may not be some
remedial work that needs to be done
and this is what concerns me there has
been no
estimate for anything in that structure
um i would i would suggest that the
council re-looks at this
and actually puts a figure in in case
remedial work
is needed thank you mr chairman
councillor hinton a question please
i hope this thing's gonna switch on
eventually yeah we're there um
one talks about council approved the
addition to the capital expenditure
program of the council spend of up to
one point one two million
but councillor halt is talking about 80
to 100 000 pounds
why the vast difference in funds
especially when he says no construction
work is going to take place this is all
about planning
and investigations etc and yet 3.1 talks
about retaining walls caffeine blocks
toilet blocks and and the whole caboodle
why do we need 3.1 at all
you don't counselor or counsellor
ward it is customary to put provision
in the capital program for major
athletes
this we do it all the time and therefore
we're putting in a provision for the
full
amount which we're going to spend of up
to 1.12 million pounds which is the
receipt from churchill
because we've uh already committed to
investing the whole of that in the park
so there is a placeholder in the capital
expenditure program
up to that value however until
we get or churchill gets if they get
planning application only the first
amount the the
the um the pre-work amount of between 80
and 100
000 pounds only that will we require
forward funding for
that we will not be seeking forward
funding for any other
aspect of the work in the whole of that
capital program including all of the
various construction elements
that help clarify
um because uh normal procedures and i'm
sure the chief executive
will pull me up on this uh with his
legal background etcetera
but normally when you're selling a piece
of land or a property or something like
that
the contracts were exchanged and that
was done on the 5th of may
but there was no completion date set
and even that even if the contracts are
completed
they could still have a reservation in
them which says subject to planning
permission
so all this preamble and all the rest of
it is completely unnecessary
completion will take place following
planning approval
that we there will be no further
the contract will not be completed until
planning is secured and that is part of
the agreement with churchill
so there won't be a completion and then
pending planning
it will it'll follow planning
thank you councillor parker yep thank
you chad
of course that that assumes that uh the
planning does come but nonetheless we're
straying into debate uh
and and um crucially straight into
debate on item 3.2
and of course we are discussing 3.1 so a
question
if i may um the recommendation in 3.1
is predicated uh upon
approving the additional or the addition
to the capital expenditure program
of 1.12 million uh and includes within
the the recommendation there at 3.1 of
the new cafe toilet block facilities
um and yet at um i think it's around
about
section six it says that at the time of
writing
the cost of providing the new cafe and
toilet block were not available
how on earth can you ask us to approve
an unknown cost of the capital
expenditure plan
council halt can you hear me all right
i'll carry on um it's usual practice to
create a budget for a new capital scheme
that hasn't yet
been subject to detail cost analysis
the detailed design and detailed costing
work
will come at the next stage of
development
that's usual practice
councillor creswell
um after hearing councillor busby's um
talking about four million going down to
two million
and might be available as from monday
which we don't know yet
i just find it astounding here we are
looking to borrow
one 1.2 million when two million might
be available as from monday
just doesn't make any sense question
please
[Music]
counselor grandin well chair the
question is what is the two million that
we have already got
reserved carried forward from last year
for this year's expenditure
on bellevue and why can't it cover the
1.12 million
does it matter it's mine
at the moment that carry forward does
not exist
until cabinet has approved it oh crikey
no but what does exist is four million
in the reserve
no no that's in
budget is not in this year's budget
can't you see that it's it's very
convenient the figure we're looking at
is 1.12 million
which with the one thing we will
guarantee is that the total cost
of the works will not come to 1.12
million
that's all that we're getting as a
revenue for the sale of the site well
that won't be the cost we don't know
what the cost of the cafe is yet we
don't even know whether we can fit one
in
we don't know what the cost of the
toilets are we don't know really because
of the work we've made estimates on them
but they could be 10 15 20 out 50
percent out
we just don't know what they will find
when they do
survey work on the old swimming pool
site
it's you know it could be anything in
there
so is there a question yeah
you think about it catherine okay
counselor
thank you chairman can i ask
can i can i ask a question see whether i
have understood things correctly please
the ac speak up can you hear me
oh can i ask a question can you hear me
now
yeah thank you um can i ask a question
see whether i've understood things
correctly
please the 80 to 100 000
pound figure that was quoted earlier by
cancer hulk
was that did i understand that that is
um like a bridging loan almost for
professional fees
and that kind of thing or have i
misunderstood basically
in many ways yes that that would be
along the right lines yes it's ford
funding for us to enable that work to be
carried out
until such time as planned mission if it
is granted is granted
and then the capital receipt comes in to
the cap to the uh council
and at that point onwards that money
would then be paid out of that capital
receipt
thank you councillor parker
um just a further question please if i
can relate it to uh to 3.1
um why is the failure of
either the developer to gain planning
permission or indeed ourselves to gain
planning permission for the proposed new
entrance
not even recorded as a risk on the risk
report
so the top risks have been uh identified
in the report there are of course
many other risks associated with the
development of this sort
um the uh third
risk i think it is on the table the
retirement living
developer withdraws and does not
complete one of the reasons they might
do that is if they fail to get planning
consent
that's written into the contract so that
particular risk is already built into
this risk identified
yes sir because
with due respect what we're discussing
here is the entrance
uh not the retirement we've already been
we're already council award already said
we're not discussing the uh
the churchill retirement scheme so my my
question is is
what if by the district council don't
achieve planning permission
uh for the uh for the new entrance why
is that not on the risk report
it's a significant risk
because at this stage the actual
decision being requested
is allocation of funds into the capital
expenditure programme
um there will be obviously further work
that is done
after the design work has been completed
and has been pointed out it is a fairly
early stage in this
in this process councillor maybe
thank you mr chairman two questions
i'm happy to ask one now and then one
later
um my first question is um
considering we've heard from council
award that two million may be available
as from monday
is this paper i.e is this not this
recommendation of 3.1
not premature we should have waited
i was going to say that as a
we had to proceed on the basis of a
council meeting this month this council
meeting was actually delayed
from earlier in the month right at the
beginning of the month
um and we we need to make
uh provision based on um
what we have the facts we have available
now
that capital um allocation
from the 2020 to 21 budget
um was a leftover for
for general works on bellevue we're
specifically looking here
at um the the receipt from churchill
and um what we intend to do with that in
terms of specific
works on our park entrance and so we
just
deemed it sensible to um for the sake of
openness and transparency to have a
specific
item in the capital expenditure program
that allocates money for this purpose
thank you councilman
i i think i think yes it's working
um i'm
sort of coming to this and i'm sort of
getting you know a bit bored
really because we should be going around
in circles
um it strikes me that we probably could
have not had this whole paper discussed
because clearly in
monday we're going to have two million
pounds yeah
which is going to be available and
presumably that would be
then put into the capital program and
you draw down on that to
achieve the reasons for the decision
which are one two and three so
we should be discussing something which
is inevitably going to happen anyway
because it's already been allocated in
previous things and the fact that
it isn't in the capital program until
it's approved
and then monday is approved because it
goes to cabinet and cabinet and
unlikely to that's a question is that a
question
um yeah the question is can we um
defer this until tuesday and then we can
obviously
go home because it's quarter to eight
i've been here since 5 30 and we're
going around the circles and i'm getting
rather fed up with this
that's my question do you want my
attention because at the moment you're
not getting it
counselor they've said
exactly what i was going to say about
deferring it all them margaret
simon what why are we talking yep we
should be deferring this
i think sorry the question i think this
has been badly presented actually
could you could you tell me why it's
been presented in this way
when you don't need to present it
because quite honestly
um you've got the decision on tuesday
[Music]
castle ward first
and i propose that we actually defer
this
uh can i have a second to please yep
i'll second book that's the beer
now we can't defer well can we get to a
vote because we need to do something
this is
absolutely this is a this is very poor
drafted
document i'm afraid that's a question
i'll put everything as a question then
it's a question what it is at the moment
the drafting of the document is is based
on
that the need primarily for 3.2 the
forward funding
provision for the preliminary work um
i'm quite happy if you wanted to um
i'd defer 3.1 or
leave 3.1 out of it reword 3.2
so that we can approve the forward
funding
um on the basis that
the cabinet decision on monday um
ratifies the carry forward from from
last year to the current financial year
and that forward funding
um is is taken out of that carry forward
and we we still need 3.2 we need to
proceed on that basis that this this
council does need to um
to approve that could i or could i ask
our monitor obviously to clarify that
particular thing with deferment thank
you chairman there are a number of
procedurals that
may be of use to the council at the
current time
uh under uh section
rule 15.1 you have the list of motions
without notice
subsection g is to withdraw a motion
so the proposer and secondary could
withdraw their motion or indeed other
members of the council could propose
that that's the case
or you could adjourn the debate on this
uh on this particular item under item k
and remember we are talking about
3.1 at present um the
alternative as as i think councillor
barrett was alluding to
is any member can ask the chair to put
an item immediately to the vote
fine what was that casa parker
thank you so before chair um thinks
about doing that can i
ask if if all of this is the case then
why on earth was this presented i i
have some sympathy with what counselor
barrett said this is a muddle
so why on earth was this presented to us
this evening and secondly
um presumably it was presented to us
this evening because it's
uh it's a significant spend surely um
and so
can it actually just be deferred to
kevin and surely it's got to come back
to council if we're talking about
uh approving an expenditure of 1.12
million
surely
[Applause]
the um the paper
was first presented to cabinet um
on the fifth of this month um and
approved there
for for onward recommendation to council
to approve
the insertion into the capital program
plus the um
the forward funding element um to allow
those preliminary works to take place
um
it is a council decision to do that um
it is what it is i'm afraid council park
army
fine okay if there's no other questions
or council parker question uh well i was
i was just going to
just respond to uh to council award on
that point
so he's agreeing with me that regardless
of whether
councillor barrett wants to defer this
for cabinet that can't be done
it's got to come it's got to be a
decision by council is is that correct
and
and with due respect council award at
the beginning of this debate
uh you did say that these two items were
entirely dependent upon each other it
turns out they're not
exactly i think
can i ask our monitoring officer emily
thank you chairman i just i just want to
clarify the reason that the decision is
being presented to the council rather
than
the cabinet and that is because that
this spend is not within the agreed
budget
as set by the council in february
therefore the cabinet cannot take a
decision that's outside agreed budget or
agreed policy
hence the capital spend needs to come
forward to council to be approved to
be entered into the capital capital
programme
thank you council buzz big question
question to emily is what spend isn't
within our control are we talking about
1.2 million or are we talking about the
100 000 that we need to spend
in advance of planning
because i think the hundred thousand
probably is
the key question is are we happy
spending a hundred thousand pounds in
advance
of knowing whether this project is going
ahead or not
a hundred thousand pounds two percent on
council tax
and the contract actually says the
seller shall supply shall apply for
and use all reasonable endeavours to
obtain all requisite
in respect to the seller's works as soon
as possible
following the grant of satisfactory
planning permission
so it's in the contract that we really
shouldn't do anything until
planning permissions received there's a
danger that we spend a hundred thousand
pounds we don't get planning permission
or they don't get planning permission
and we've wasted that hundred thousand
pounds because we might look
might need a totally different solution
but if we need the hundred thousand
pounds then i underst
my reading of the accounts again which
may not be valid until monday is that in
the business rates pilot
there's a hundred and seventy seven
thousand pounds
unspent on hamilton road
boreham gate and bellevue so the funds
are there
we don't have to borrow it it's a case
of whether we're happy to spend it
and perhaps it might be wasted
it might be wasted saying it will be but
it could be
are you happy to flick a coin and
waste a hundred thousand pounds or not
counterarthy um thank you chairman yeah
it seems to me that council of busbee is
addressing 3.2
you have said that we're dealing with
3.1
separately and we're dealing with that
first can i make a point without
asking a question i don't know when
you're going to move on to debate
well if if there are no other questions
then i am prepared to
go to the vote on 3.1 not the vote the
debate
yeah debate okay councillor mayberry
well
thank you mr chairman this is my sister
well it depends whether councillor maybe
is asking a question i suppose
yeah yeah right i'll defer to councillor
maybe
this is this is my second um question
that i did
allude to i would like to know
why did baber agree to build
the retaining wall as part of this sale
because this is where we are becoming
unstuck
why on earth did we agree to build the
divide the retaining wall thank you
councillor halt
i'm getting a bit fed up with this
debate to be honest because yeah
councilman maybe
quite should understand as should every
member here
understand that the park entrance
was spoken about and brought forward
through the sudbury steering group
way in advance of this land sale way in
advance
and this park entrance has been brought
forward
separately once that land was sold
to churchill then a subsequent
consultation
happened and it made common sense
that if we were going to going to go
ahead with this park entrance
we would have to build a wall because we
will sell in the other section of land
and it makes perfect sense for this
scheme to go forward
in relation to doing the feasibility
work
so that we can abide by the contract
we've gone into
and should they get planned with mission
the time scale fits
if we don't do this pre-work now
and church you'll get that plan of
permission we will struggle to hit
our contractual commitments that we've
made
in the sale of the land to churchill
now as i say that park entrance was out
in the public or certainly in the
steering group
way before that land was sold so it
isn't the case that we've got to build
the wall
for churchill we've got to build the
wall for a park
entrance because the levels this has
been explained
need that holding ball retaining wall
we are talking about here a park
entrance to enhance the park
bellevue for sudbury this park needs
that work this park needs revitalizing
and this is the scheme to do it now the
pre-work we're on about
is to enable that work
to be done so that we're in a position
to go forward
should planner permission be granted the
1.2 million that will go into
in the capital works program and added
to two million
it's the four million sat there for
quite some time it's not
automatically going to be drawn down and
it won't be drawn down
we're talking about eight eighty two
hundred thousand
until we get that capital receipt in no
more work will happen
it it seems quite straightforward to me
perhaps i'm just being naive here but i
can't see why members
are constantly having this argument what
don't you do not trust that we're going
to do the honourable thing do you not
trust what we
what we intend to do is there some
debate here about trust because if
that's the case then come out and say it
because i'm a little bit fed up with it
to be honest
mr chairman not the argument the
argument is or the
debate is um
if the churchill don't get planning
application and if therefore we don't
sell that chunk of land
do we have to put the same retaining
walls up and i don't believe you do
because
the retaining walls are there to protect
a four-storey
block of flats
around a technical point the retaining
wall is to facilitate the park
entrance it is not there as a structural
solution for churchill
or anybody else it is not there to
ensure that a four-story building can be
built
it is to facilitate the split of the
land into two
areas and to facilitate our park
entrance because
we are digging down to be able to enable
people to come in from
from the pavement into the park entrance
at that point
i hope that clarifies matters thank you
castle parker
yep thank you chairman and um we're
we're into debate now aren't we so i'd
i'd just like to
um just say to council hold on i'm sorry
that he's fed up with the debate but
this is the paper that cabinet have
presented to council
and so if it's not been made clear i
think kavanaugh needs to take a long
look at itself and i also think that
the confusion the inability for anybody
or seemingly for for uh well for whoever
to be able to differentiate between 3.1
and 3.2
shows the model that we're in so if we
can deal with 3.1
which is requesting uh the capital
edition of uh
or the addition to the capital
expenditure program of 1.12 million
um just to come back to your point um
council hold i don't
think any of us have got an issue with
the fact that bellevue needs to be
improved
the issue that we've got here is that we
have got absolutely no guarantee that we
will ever receive that capital receipt
i'm quite sure that we will
but we've got no cast iron guarantees
that we're going to receive that 1.12
million
now if that's the case we will end up
bearing in mind that the entrance has
been designed
in uh in in or alongside
the planning permission sorry alongside
the development
that has been approved by cabinet the
entrance has been designed alongside
that so if the receipt for 1.12 million
never comes forward
we will have spent up to 1.12 million
pounds creating an
an entrance that will turn out to be
alluding back to
alluding back to council of beers point
earlier we will have we will have built
an entrance
that is irrelevant to the development
that would then have to come forward
council
which has been written to sudbury town
council no work will commence
on that site until planner permission is
granted
that's you you you're basically trying
to say that we're going to build it
anyway
and spend 1.2 million with due respect
council
with due respect council halt that's
exactly what you said was going to
happen in the cabinet meeting on the 5th
of july
you said you would be developing an
entrance a park entrance
whatever alternative sources of income
might
might be able to be gained alternative
sources of income in that case we don't
need
3.1 yes we do
[Music]
lindsey i have uh questions from
councilmen to council councillor hinton
councilman avery and cancer oscar sorry
mr chairman are we in debate
or are we well we seem to have drifted
into debate
asking the thing keep to the question
can i suggest we go into debate because
we've spent long enough on questions and
we are going round and round
so can i suggest we now go into debate
clive wanted to start the debate off
and then after a few minutes can i
suggest that we go to the vote because
we're just going round and round in
circles
thank you chairman yes i think that's
actually quite a good idea because
i think the meeting is starting to lose
its structure
what we've been having sounds a lot like
debate to me but with people being able
to speak multiple times
which is not what's supposed to happen
the point i was going to make was simply
about 3.1
because we're we're dealing just with
3.1
and i don't think 3.1 is a model at all
the paper is about what we propose to do
and the point is that we have said
the churchill capital receipt is to be
used in full
um on bellevue park and entrance so it's
absolutely no coincidence at all that
3.1 is asking for approval of that
amount
as an addition to the capital
expenditure program
it should be in our capital expenditure
program because it's what we plan to do
and in order to spend that money it's
capital and it has to come out of our
capital expenditure
so i'm happy with 3.1 splitting from 3.2
i think that most of the points that
have been made are about 3.2
i don't think there's any question at
all about 3.1
i think that we should approve it now
absolutely um
councillor lindsay is this a quest i
shall only now be asking for the
questions
and as a councillor arthur has alluded
to
we've already strayed into debate and uh
let you know if we're going to get this
over there are no other questions
we'll just go into debate and go to the
uh vote on that
on 3.1
it's been answered thank you all right
councillor creswell
right right first of all i'd ask the
question to
councillor halt when councillor holt
said it was discussed with sudbury
steering committee
i wouldn't say it was disgust i said you
came there with your officers
and it was a bit like a dictatorship i'm
not gonna lie
they came back with things that you told
them that was gonna happen
there was no debate between
the sudbury town council and and
yourselves you came down there you
already had the answers
so and as for standing there and saying
a four-story wall is con conducive no
it's not it's to hold a four-story
building up as dave busby said
let's be honest about things let's stop
telling lies let's be honest with the
public
thank you chairman chairman if i could
intervene at that point
i'm not comfortable with councillors
accusing officers of lying in a public
meeting
that's not appropriate it's a contrary
to the code of conduct in relation to
officer member relationships
perfectly reasonable for counselors to
hold robust views and to do so with each
other
but please can ask councillors not to
stray into the suggestion that officers
are lying
your officers do not lie to you your
officers give you their facts and their
opinion their advice
it is for you to make decisions based
upon that advice and guidance
and you can follow it or you cannot
follow it but do not please accuse
officers of lying
or trying to mislead you that is not
what they are doing if
as has happened here an officer has made
it very clear to you
that the works that are proposed are
nothing to do
with the construction of the building
that has not even been granted planning
permission yet
but it's to do with the construction of
an entrance which cabinet have approved
then that is the case if you wish to
take that outside of the meeting with
myself as chief executive then i'm more
than happy to do so
but as repeated before do not accuse
officers of lying
please
could i come back then certainly i'd
also like to come back and uh just say
that to
council creswell i believe he's not a
member of the steering group so i'm not
quite sure where he's getting his
information from
i can respond to that because i um speak
to the
person who was on the steering committee
and they went in there
and that's that isn't dealt with in the
right way i'm sorry what you might think
councilman and
[Music]
under procedure rule 15.1
can we have a question and we move to
the vote
that is indeed a valid motion without
notice you do need a seconder and you
need to
uh to vote on that
propose i propose that we move to the
vote under 15.1
uh councillor second
so i shall go straight into the vote now
on 3.1 no
you need to take a vote as to whether to
move to the vote yeah so i need to yeah
i'm sorry thank you thank you i need to
um
go to the uh members to decide whether
we will vote on the
on the um motion that's gone through
check can we um can we just have a hands
up for for putting it straight
for putting 3.1 to the vote rather than
going through the voting system so if
hands up for all of those in favor of
going straight to 3.1 to vote
chair that is carried so we're going to
to vote on recommendation 3.1
counts as that is now showing in blue
and
if you go to the vote and place your
vote please thank you
oh okay
chair we have two members who i believe
have left them the meeting which is
councillor beer and councillor newman
so the votes are 4 11
and against the 3.1 recommendation 14
one abstention so actually
that recommendation is lost
thank you thank you the recommendation
is lost on 3.1
shall we um now go forward to 3.2
so we need to counter parker
share i um i'd like to propose an
amendment to 3.2 if possible
yes certainly would you like the wording
of the amendment
please please so the
amendment 3.2 the council authorized
forward funding of essential works by
borrowing until the capital
receipt is received to enable the
commissioning of a multi-disciplinary
professional team to support and deliver
the stakeholder and community engagement
and detailed design work surveys and
investigations
planning principal contractor
procurement liaison with the retirement
living developers professional team
including party war matters within the
required time
time frame any such borrowing should
only be considered once
existing reserves or other sources of
external funding have been exhausted
thank you councillor parker have i heard
second day
counselor you wish to speak
okay we're going straight to um
questions on 3.2
oh council ward
do you accept the amendment only if the
word
reserves is taken out of it
and i'll explain why
it is true that reserves can be used for
capital programme
but that would deplete our reserves
we cannot use the capital receipt
receipt
to replenish the reserves that we have
used capital receipts can only be used
for capital expenditure
or to repay borrowing so um
it can keep the other sources of funding
but um
take out the word reserves
before i um exceed or otherwise to that
counsellor
award can i can i just ask um because i
think council busby mentioned it earlier
in your papers on monday you'll you'll
be discussing the
um um forgive me
um what's the name of the fund the
business rates pilot
scheme uh in which there sits 102
according to the papers that you'll be
looking at on monday this is 186 000
pounds of funds
that have been placed there specifically
to be spent
at um hamilton road and also uh bellevue
so so the question is i mean i hear what
you're saying and i understand that the
capital receipt can't replenish the
reserve
but why does it need to why do we need
to borrow if we've got 186
000 and council hall tells us that we
need to spend between 80 and 100
we've got the money um so uh if
if a reserve is a rainy day fund is this
not the ultimate rainy day
available for further work in sudbury
and that's what that retention pilot
um fund was for but um uh
if this council's will to use that and
deplete that fund
so that we can do less in the town then
um
but with due respect mr chairman if i
may with due respect
you are expecting a capital receipt of
1.12 million pounds which you can use
for other projects in town can you not
we've already made a commitment to spend
all of that on the park
if you wish us to divert some of that to
other projects instead
again um happy to consider that
councillor hinton castle award sorry no
just for clarity is the amendment as
proposed by councillor parker accepted
or not i think the answer is not
i heard the subject too but i didn't
hear council parker agree to that uh
yeah i'm not if the word reserve is
still in there i
i just wish that word was uh taken out
and then i'd accept the amendment so
councillor parker are you happy to
remove
the word reserve i'm i'm i'm i think
it's regretful i i i think it's dark but
yes
um chair i'll i'll happily remove the
word reserve in which case then the
in which case the amendment is accepted
so there's no need to go to a vote
so i'm going to go into questions
so i shall now ask for questions
which obviously you can have as many as
you wish
but the uh debate will rely on
allowed for three minutes to speak by
each member
and can i just remind uh councillors
that
not to preamble on a question which will
end up as a debate thank you
councillor lindsay so i
i think members colleagues i think
that's
better obviously there's not a lot of
point going on
the decision has already been made
effectively but i did want to
ask the question why we entered into a
contract
with a private developer that committed
us to borrowing
100k before we had any guarantee
that it would be that the development
would go ahead
um the 100 000 isn't
for the commitment to the developer it's
for pre-design work
and feasibility associated with the park
entrance the cafe
the new toilets and the retaining wall
so there's a there's a bit of design
work that needs to go
out of that hundred thousand towards the
retaining wall which as i've already
explained
is actually to create the new park
entrance uh
so um it just happens to be that the the
developer needs to have the two sites
split
in order for them to complete the sale
so it's less about retaining and more
about splitting the two sides
councillor can i come back chair or
thank you mr chairman um
i'll be working again yet oh mr pokemon
paper yeah
um quick question really and i'll skate
around it a little bit
because of it comes out of the pink
papers
there is nothing in the timetable in the
pink papers to say
when the the
churchill are likely to be putting in a
planning application
and also within there it says sill
preparation
cafe toilet towards october 21 2021
round submissions that has funding being
sourced from there
how much money do we need for this
entrance excuse
me councillor hinton you are going into
the pink paper which is confidential
so please refrain from that question
why are we sourcing money from lots of
different places for the same thing
am i going to be vague
or the temporal
we have a couple of seats hopefully
coming of 1.12 million
if we are able to get further funding in
addition to that
then obviously we would be reckless if
we didn't do so
as a council if we're able to get
funding for various parts of the park
improvements then we will do so
on top of that what you end up with then
is
possibly some capital left over that
perhaps we can do something else within
in in sudbury because
not only did we commit to putting that
totally into the park but he also said
if there was anything left and i believe
if john
can correct me if i'm wrong there would
be spent in sudbury
so if we were able to get grants if
we're able to get other funding that
will just leave more money to be spent
in sudbury
and i don't see anything wrong with that
so you know if we can't get the grants
if we can't get an additional funding
that capital receipt will be used for
the park
now i my understanding was that the
capital was
used for bellevue park
and sudbury um and obviously
this development won't qualify for sill
so if you apply to the sill fund for
extra money
you're effectively robbing other parts
of the district of potential uh
infrastructure
spending how is this uh equitable for
the
people of baylor
to sell funding are you you referring to
it's in the pink papers if you want to
go into the pink papers council award
we'll go
into this i'll talk about it do you want
to but i've been told that i'm not to be
specific about things because
do you want to enter a confidential
session
well you can see you can see the papers
in front of you the same as i can
if you want to enter confidential
security i don't think we need to think
that
funding is in reference to the total
project
at this point we're only looking at the
hundred thousand
which is the price pre-spending before
the planning application is approved or
not
council plum thank you chairman i would
like to
propose that we move to a vote i hope
someone will second me on that
finished questions yeah no i'm asking a
question
question council lindsay and then
councillor no that's just seconding the
uh
second that okay yeah thank you
[Music]
yeah mr chairman councillor mabry has
been waiting for some time to ask a
question
i shall ask questions now if you'd like
to ask a question
thank um thank you mr chairman patience
is always a virtue
um my question
the biggest question here is
why on earth did baber agree to sell
this piece of land
without getting the contribution from
the developer to actually build this
entrance
that's the biggest question is the
question that's never been answered
and it probably without any shaking of
heads
it really does need an answer
in normal terms a developer
comes into a parish and i'm going to use
the town as a parish
they wish to do certain things and
we are always asking what a contribution
could be i know we sold the piece of
land but
surely we should have been forward with
this
thinking okay in relative terms
they are not paying that large amount of
money for that site
so why were we not asking for this
the entrance to be built because the
retirement living
is not going to attract any affordable
flats it's not going to attract s106
and it's not going to attract any seal
payment to the district
so that's the biggest question and it's
the question in the room that has
never been answered or perhaps even
asked
thank you are any responses here
i think um councillor holt referred to
this earlier the
park entrance was designed before
we went out to market on the on the
other side
um so whilst the contracts exchanged
in may the park entrance had already
been designed at that point
and it is something that the cabinet
have approved because
it's what the cabinet wanted to to do
for the park so the current entrance to
the park
um it doesn't have to be replaced there
is already another entrance
uh admittedly not facing the town but
this entrance was something that was
discussed
long before the site was put on the
market um
and i think it's um it's not a debate
that i
particularly feel like an answer in
terms of why churchill weren't asked to
contribute
the churchill scheme hasn't been through
planning yet they haven't submitted a
planning application yet
so that feels to me like a planning
question
all right thank you for that i'm
proposing to go forward to
uh get the vote on whether we
go forward on the uh amended amendment
i do believe we're voting on councillor
parker's amendment
well i was the seconder to that and you
did ask him
if he agreed and rewording but you
didn't ask me
i do no that's fine chairman i do agree
it's common sense i just like things to
be annoyed i think we've seen enough
embarrassment this is the worst debate
i've ever attended to be honest so
let's get it right on the vote please
thank you
chair i just want to raise um your
attention to the fact that we do have a
motion on the table
proposed by councillor plum and seconded
by councillor lindsay
which is that the question now be put so
the council does need to vote on moving
directly to the vote
on the amended motion and
chair i'd suggest in the same manner as
we did previously that the council can
indicate their
approval otherwise by sheriff hands
the point being that we haven't started
debate yet i mean councillor lindsay has
proposed that it be
and we haven't even had the debate yet
[Music]
all we've always had is questions well
yep sorry let me take the motion
if cancer arthur wants some debate
i will allow it i'll withdraw seconding
the
the move to a vote i'll withdraw it
but let's have something relevant in the
debate
please all right casper i'm going back
over history thank you
thank you chairman i think it's only
right that we have debate i think it's a
bit silly if we have
just a few questions and then we move
straight to the to the vote
um i wanted to make a couple of points
really
um one of them triggered by what
councilor hinton said
when he said he understood the receipt
was going to be spent on
bellevue i think he's right and i think
we all understood that
so how 3.1 was lost i've got absolutely
no idea
i'm glad that councillor parker has
accepted
the changes to the amendment proposed by
council award
to take out the reference to use of
reserves
and the reason i'm pleased that he did
that is because if you put together the
vote for 3.1
and the original amendment for 3.2
we would have a situation where we were
flying in the face
of the decision we made to spend the
receipt
from churchill on bellevue park we would
effectively be saying
no we're not going to a capital receipt
go into capital and and put it into
into our program for work on bellevue's
we've just had that vote
and then we'd be saying we're not going
to spend any of it on the preliminary
works either that's going to come out of
reserves
and i think that is completely contrary
to what we have previously agreed and i
actually think it's completely contrary
to what most people actually want
thank you councillor
are there any other wishing to speak on
debate
three minutes cancel lindsey
counselor arthi wanted a bait i'll give
him one
not really j i i um
i think the the issue um
that sort of bothers me um
[Music]
so what is we're just going straight for
this is 3.2 so we're talking about
borrowing
we're just going straight to borrowing
and it does say reserves in
other sources of funding in there but i
just really want to emphasize that
or ask perhaps you know we're mentioned
somewhere in here about seeking other
sources of funding
but if we want to improve a public open
space
in our largest market town where's the
where's the research where's the where's
the bidding from public bodies
that specialize specializing just that i
mean you've gone to the lrf
for 500k but that's the money to enhance
development
not to enhance public space so i i
really want there's nothing in this i
can see
that shows we've been to um
english heritage or national lottery
fund or anywhere like that
to get to get money to spend on a public
space
for the people of baber
i i just don't i don't understand why
we've got to go straight into borrowing
money
to to build to to do these pre
i understand it's pre-construction works
but
but i don't i don't understand why we
have to
while we're not seeking money from from
funders that actually want
whose goal is to to create and improve
public open space
thank you council lindsey anybody else
wish to speak to the into the debate
3.2
now councillor parker are you any final
comments please
uh no none from me uh chairman thank you
councilman
first thank you sorry question debate
all is chair i'd like the motion and
it's
uh when it's been amended to be read out
again so we all know
exactly what we're voting for because
since that was read out
we've had a lot of debate a lot of
questions and i think we might have lost
track where we were
with it so i think it would be a good
thing for it to be read out again
good point council care as well could we
have the
amendment read again please
yeah thank you so the amendment as i
have it is that cancer authorize
forward funding of essential works by
borrowing
until that capital receipt is received
to enable the commissioning of a
multi-disciplinary
professional team to support and deliver
the stakeholder
and community engagement and detailed
design work
surveys and investigations planning
principal contractor procurement liaison
with the retirement living developers
professional team
including party wall matters within the
required time frame
any such borrowing should only be
considered once other sources of
external funding
have been exhausted
thank you thank you any any other
council parker would you like to add
anything to the
amendment
council ward thank you chairman
um well it's certainly been an
interesting debate this evening
um there have been quite a few
technicalities which uh
i know we seem to have struggled with
which is unfortunate and and for that i
apologize
um but it uh it has been
a very technical report unfortunately
now i know that some
some people don't approve of our plans
for the site and and would like to stop
them
in the hope that an alternative could be
found
however we have looked at many options
for a new entrance
and this really does represent the only
viable one
is something that can be delivered and
crucially
funded rather than a pine sky scheme
that would never see the light of day
the combined projects retain and protect
the house
and deliver the improved park entrance
that our exhibition and consultation in
january last year
showed that the public rightly wanted to
see
not to do something and instead give in
to the small but vocal number of
objectives
would be to do a great disservice to the
town and its residents
it would mean yet another delay in
renovating the park and it could be many
years before this council summons up the
will to make another attempt
i hope our members have been reassured
and not just that it's a worthy project
but that we have planned it well
we have considered the financing and
planning permission pending it has every
chance of success
and being a wonderful showcase for the
town thank you chairman
thank you councilwood
our members i'd now like to go to the
vote and unless um
uh councillor haran has anything to to
add
before we go
government gives everybody a chance
to do the right thing and for the
cabinet to come back with better
worded proposals and i'm confident that
we can all do that
that's all i have to say chairman i
shall be supporting the amendment
thank you councillor haran um well very
close to the guillotine on this so
i don't like to go to the vote now
thank you chair the vote is now in blue
if councillors could vote as soon as
possible please thank you
that's half past eight all right
can i ask councillors if they wish to
extend the uh
guillotine uh past half past eight so we
only have a minute could i have a show
of hands please
it's simply to enable the vote to go
through because it's being processed so
it we won't keep you more than probably
another minute but it's just to make
sure for procedural completeness
and i had counsellors i want to make
sure that we're procedurally correct
thank you chair i just have now got the
voting through so
it's 21 full three against and one
abstention
three have left the meeting so that is
actually carried thank you so that uh
yes that
amendment is carried and thank you very
much councillors
um what else have we got to go on here
all right well that concludes the
meeting
with that um debate and questions which
seem to all roll into one however um
the next meeting will be on the uh
21st september at 5 30
and i'm hopefully
going to have to or hopefully our
officers will be able to
have our meeting at our endeavor house
chamber however it is not it's
you know it's entirely up to the way
this coded regulations go
so thank you all members for attending
and thank you for
your input into the debates
thank you
you